any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic get out
as quickly as possible
all right i appreciate you stephen
kotler today's guest on the into the
impossible podcast appropriate because
his awesome new book
is the art of the impossible and we're
going to talk about so many things in an
impossibly short amount of time
steven you're a cleveland boy just like
me at least i went to college at case
western
where it was discovered that the
universe
does not need an ether a supporting
medium to propagate light waves and it
was thought to be impossible
for millennia for light to travel
through a vacuum without some kind of
underlying medium what do you make of
the fact that there are these paradigms
that need to be overthrown in order for
our perceptions of reality
to be shaken towards a common good that
we
have to break through and really do the
impossible
and there's so much resistance to it
even though on the other side
lies truth lies true reality why are
humans so resistant
to achieving the art of the impossible
so i don't know if i have to answer
exactly
that question that's a hard question um
i want to back off on that what i
here's here's here's what i can tell you
you know 30 years of studying those the
the right
this has been my beat as as a journalist
as an author as
a peak performance researcher those
moments in time when the impossible
became possible
and after 30 years of doing this work
two things seem
overwhelmingly clear one is that we're
all capable of so much more than we know
two is that and this is the key point
human capability
is invisible human potential is
invisible
especially to ourselves and it's
invisible to ourselves for a lot of like
you know really clear well understood
reasons
at this point for example uh potential
is an emergent property
we only can find out we're capable of by
using our skills
to the utmost again and again and again
over long stretches of time
and human development happens in like
fits and starts right it's like
punctuated equilibrium
so we can't have long plateaus where it
doesn't feel like anything is going on
and then sudden bursts
blow so that's part of the problem
another portion of the problem is
this is not my research adam grant's
contributed to a bunch of other people
have worked on it
but you don't know we don't know
what we're going to be good at and what
we're going to like
until after we've done it not before and
to the point of
if you if i were to lebron james and
said bronn
let's say lebron has never played
badminton before right
i don't know if he has but he's let's
say he's never played badminton before i
say brawn
you want to play badminton do you think
you'll be good at it do you
think you'll like it this is one of the
greatest athletes
on the planet currently and the research
says he won't know
if he'll like a physical another
physical skill that's like
adjacent to basketball or if they be any
good at it
until he tries it like we really don't
know
what we're capable of on top of that
we have all kinds of built-in time
horizons in the brain and limitation
horizons that actually
shape perspective a bit so it's a
complicated answer but there's a lot of
biology there
um and uh development is sort of stacked
this way this is a principle in science
known as the banister effect you have to
believe the impossible as possible
before it becomes possible
right it's because of very tight
correlations between physiology
and psychology so there's a lot there's
there's a whole lot of
stuff underneath this because we could
spend an hour yeah
actually yeah i was going to bring up
the banister effect in the cosmic
microwave background research that i do
there's this little beach ball behind me
it was discovered in 1965
by penzias and wilson and then
immediately after it was discovered this
heroic feat of detecting this radiation
pattern 454 degrees below
zero fahrenheit immediately afterwards
people verified it
and it was thought to be impossible for
literally decades before
and then all of a sudden there's a slew
of confirmations detections
and that is crucial to the scientific
method what be what was thought to be
impossible what was impossible
is then later has to be replicated in
other words it has to be done
eminently possible in order for science
to be to be verified right
for sure that's true i mean i think
that's true anywhere right it um
you see it in athletics they talk a lot
about in action sports where people are
routinely
you know doing things that not only like
look physically impossible if they go
wrong you're gonna die
right so there's you don't you've got to
do the impossible you've got to get it
right because they're moral consequences
for error but they talk a lot about how
the first person through the door has
one challenge
everybody else they know it's you know
it's not possible for example
in park skiing right this is freestyle
skiing somebody just threw the very
first
quad that's four flips um
nobody thought it was possible and you
can literally like you
talk to him before it and then the
minute it happened another
banister effect right suddenly 11 other
people
threw quads in the next like three weeks
this was a feat that we thought was
might have been like defined the laws of
physics impossible we didn't actually
think you could
quite do it kind of stuff so we see it
all over the place
talk about the different people we've
had one of your uh collaborators and
friends peter diamandis on the show
in a past episode about a year ago with
the book you guys wrote together one of
the many books you guys have written
together
uh and talk about the difference in the
type of impossible feats that he
and you speak about and that he has done
and you have done and
your friend laird hamilton is there is
there a similarity between those
so let me let me sort of give you an
overview of my career my work with peter
in the frame of the impossible because
uh it's easy so i have written uh
14 books if you ignore the
novels 12 of them six of them are on
technology and six are on peak
performance
why is this the case my core subject is
what does it take to do the impossible
right those moments in time and i've
done this in every domain
imaginable whenever you see the
impossible become possible you tend to
see
the same two things you see people
learning to harness and leverage
disruptive accelerating technology right
and you see people learning to extend
human capability
when these things come together you get
the impossible people forget
laird is credited with the millennium
wave
revolutionizing surfing showing us how
50
foot waves were possible what people
don't for don't remember
as much as the wave runner that allowed
him to toe into those waves
didn't show up until the late 80s this
was a brand new
technology right shane mcconkey who i
read a lot about
rise as superman who's legendary as
maybe the most pioneering action sport
athlete in history he's a skier
and he did things that nobody thought
was possible but he also
invented a new kind of fatsky that for
the first time ever
absorbed way more shock and where did
you get the materials
out of developments in the aerospace
industry which crept into surfing
via southern california connections and
then into skiing
through the game up the coast into town
right this is like
this is just technological development
suddenly there were whiz-bang materials
that could make skis that you know
worked in a variety of conditions and
they revolutionized sport we don't talk
about that much
that much i do in my book rise as
superman that really looks at this
question
but you see so you gotta if you're
really interested in solving this
problem
you need to harness both sides i think
uh talk about one of these things that
you know we authors and you've written
so many more books than i have but i
know one thing my publisher wouldn't let
me
touch the cover of the book but i always
judge books by their cover
i know most people say not to do that
but what else do you have to judge a
book by
other than the cover and the title i
love the title the art of the impossible
talk about the cover talk about the
subtitle
the p a peak performance primer
well so i i unlike you
i'm a nut bag about my covers so i do
mine and since i mean since i started
like i
demand i've designed most of my covers
including that one
um i worked very heavily with the
designer the the designer uh
found that image that was an image that
we actually created the flow
research collective originally um the
image and why it's important is
simply this when we say peak human
performance
what does that mean what does p
performance mean what is it right we
talk about peak performance you need it
for the impossible duty
what is peak performance peak
performance is nothing more or less
than getting our biology to work for us
rather than against us
and what this book really is is we've
known about it it focuses on cognitive
performance but we've we know about
all the different elements we've heard
about focus or grit or motivation or
mindfulness or flow i've written some of
these books right but what has happened
in the past four or five years
that this book does that i don't think
it's been done before is
we now know this shouldn't be surprising
especially with you it's a system
our biology is a system it's designed to
work in a certain way in a certain order
and if you get the order right the way
it's designed to work obviously
you go farther faster with a lot less
fuss right this is not
surprising anybody um but it's new
and so that's what this book does that's
those are the science behind
it there was a second half to your
question oh pink performance farmer
this is so they are impossible is this
big
huge title with a big promise and
it's uh it's legit this is literally
lessons learned
from people who have accomplished the
impossible uh for all of us to
significantly level out of our game and
if we're not going after capital i
impossible that which has never been
done
it's a how-to for how to go after small
line possible that which we believe is
impossible for ourselves
that said science
has an anti-hyperbole tradition they
have a tradition of understatement
and this is a neuroscience-based book i
study the neurobiology of peak human
performance
and i do this you know the flow research
collective we work in conjunction with
scientists at ucla
at stanford at usc at imperial college
london
our team is psychology phd psychologist
and phd neuroscientist
and um that's what we focus on
and in science especially if you're
going to have a great big
grandiose thing that comes before the
colon
you better have something like humble
and downstated
and quiet like i always i tried this was
so this was an argument in my
my marriage for a really long time i
grew up in a tradition of action sports
where people are literally doing crazy
[ __ ] so everything's understated
and science where people are exploring
possible [ __ ] so everything's always
understated and that's how we roll in
these communities
so like my idea of a compliment is
there's a famous story about wolfgang
paulie
einstein gives this famous lecture right
and
afterwards everyone in the auditorium
this is in switzerland this is after
he's won his nobel
every speechless the entire room is
speechless
and wolfgang paulie is 19 years old
arrogant is all get out and he pops to
his feet and goes you know
but mr einstein said he's not so stupid
and so for me the height of a compliment
is oh that
that's not so stupid right because
wolfgang paulie said it is
and i i discovered in marriage that if
you don't know who wolfgang paulie is
your wife will get very upset
if you say things like oh that idea it's
not so stupid when you mean oh that's
freaking genius
so but in this case yeah in this case
the peak performance because it is a
pre-performance product that's what it
is it's a blueprint
it's a how-to book and it uses
the neurobiology of peak human
performance to outline hey there are
four
skill sets four categories of skill sets
you need to perform your best if you're
interested in possible
you're capitalized small i or you just
like you want
to be a little more productive and work
on monday and maybe for your kids to be
a little less annoying
the biology is the same right and
there's four categories of that biology
and that's what the book breaks down and
a
performance primer is my like first of
all it's my nod
to scientists especially like when the
book goes to europe
right and like it's my like hey
i understand what tradition i'm working
in here i've got my big fancy title
because it helps sell it but i'm also
saying hey
look i i get there's a side to this
story and i need to be
you know humble also because you know
the real truth
as you know in science is ap performance
primer
for right now right because five years
from now 10 years from now
forget about it like this is why we call
it science it's a
living evolving discussion and while the
principles i'm writing about are
foundational biology
our knowledge of how that biology is
working is advancing exponentially so to
believe that like this is the end all be
all you know it's the best i think we
know
as of today but i think 10 years from
now somebody else is going to like
you know eat my lunch for me well i want
to talk about this small eye versus big
eye and i kind of read the title as
sort of in audrey hepburn's language her
famous quote nothing is impossible
the very word itself says i'm possible
capital i
possible right so i want to ask you uh
in the in the context of of the personal
the application where the capital i
and the way i took away from the book
you talk about metrics in the in the in
the moment and you say
how do i measure progress how do you
know to truly developing this particular
habit we're talking about ferocity
in part one um and i'm thinking just in
my putting on my hat
of developing the micro skills and
interviewing on this podcast
and and i'm gonna betray that right now
because i'm gonna ask a long-winded
question
but i've often wondered when i'm giving
when i'm doing an interview how do i
know i'm doing a good job
because you know you don't know until
after the fact when it comes out maybe
the author will promote it maybe they
won't
maybe the audience will give it thumbs
up maybe they won't maybe they'll share
it maybe they won't
by the way please do share it please do
give it a thumbs up but the bottom line
is in the moment how do i know i'm doing
a good job
are there ways that are there tools are
there tactics that i can know
um and kind of use as metrics to apprise
am i doing a good job in this particular
set of micro skills that we call
podcasting or interviewing
so that's i'm not asking you by the way
to grade how i'm doing you yeah no no
that like there's that is a massive
question but let me try to just
one immediate feedback
is crucial for performance right and
in fields where feedback is
more delayed for example the difference
between surgeons and radiologists
surgeons immediate feedback patient
either lives or dies you know how you
did right if there's blood in the cavity
this scalpel slipped foundational role
of surgery right
radiologists they look at a radiological
scan
and maybe six months from now they
figure out was their diagnosis of cancer
real or not real did the patient live or
die but most of them never find out
this is why by the way if you track
surgical medical skills
almost every class of physician skills
decline post medical school
except for surgeons it's because of real
time feedback tells us that in
professions where there are
there's in my profession writing
would to say that you have a publisher
and an editor at the it's a lie
right you know this your editors don't
edit they show up twice in a book
read it and give you overlying notes
that's not like
i have a guy who is on my salas
uh staff who's my editor he reads
everything i write
after i read it twice a week because
that's the feedback
i need right so you have to
and when it comes to podcasting here's
something weird because there's a caveat
here and this is why i said i could talk
forever
this comes out of educational research
into flow
quick definition for those of you who
don't know what flow is optimal state of
consciousness where we feel our best and
perform our best
that's the scientific definition more
specifically it's
any of those moments of wrapped
attention and total absorption we get so
focused on what we're doing
extra awareness merges our sense of self
diminishes time passes strength we get
so sucked in and an hour goes by and
we're like what what happened
right and throughout all aspects of
performance mental and physical
go through the roof you can go to way
more detail later but that's the quick
shorthand for
flow here's something that we learned
from education research
so flow tends to flow states have
triggers preconditions that lead to more
flow one of the most important is the
challenge skills balance
we get into flow the most we pay the
most attention to the task at hand
when the challenge slightly exceeds our
skill set so think about
educators a teacher you're a high school
teacher you're
inflow in front of the class why are you
in flow because you're not just teaching
history you're on the edge of your
knowledge telling about all the cool
[ __ ] that you discovered right that's
when teachers inflow
you have now lost every one of your
students so literally there's
overwhelming research that shows in
education if you're not if you don't
know what you're doing
when the teacher's in flow oftentimes
the students are not and when the
students are in flow
teachers not so sometimes
right and the other thing about peak
performance that is very tricky
and my answer the short answer is
self-awareness is important but you also
have to figure out where the signals
mean so you need a translation for the
signals like the art embossed with
something else i'll give you another
example
in peak performance your emotions don't
always mean
what you think they mean so let me give
you a simple example
frustration for most people is a sign
that they're moving in the wrong
direction but if you're interested in
flow at the front of an end of every
flow state there is a
struggle phase you it more and more
evidence is pointing to the fact that
you may have to trigger the fight
response even for a millisecond
to get into flow right this is why if
you've ever made the classic
how to go to the hospital on a mountain
bike error of i went out for a flowy
bicycle ride
mountain biking is an aggressive sport
if you go out
trying to be flowy you're going to be
risk averse you're going to get bounced
to the bike and you're going to end up
in the hospital you have to attack the
hill
and then you drop into flow it right so
and this is the case
we know this from science right you
you're gonna have to
battle the ideas around in your head and
like for me
i always say i if i have if you haven't
reversed my position once along the way
completely taken everything i thought
was right and told me it was wrong
i haven't done science right that's not
science yet
science is what happens once i solve
something
discover it then get overturned and then
come back and fix it
like to me that's like the game right
then i'm like okay i can trust this
and now i can trust this smart people
have beat on this it's not just me
that's right that's what feynman said
violent side of science is the belief in
the ignorance of experts because if you
just trust the experts then we would
never have gone from newton to einstein
weinstein said oh newton's pretty smart
let me just rest on newton
it's well it's also you you hit this a
bunch in the beginning
and it's you know whatever we want to
talk about the banister effect or all
these big
big things it's really a subtle thing
it's the
reframing is
so so so so crucial to
um psychology to pick performance to
innovation to creativity like it is one
of the most powerful
cognitive tools we have and it's how
paradigm shifts occur
right that's the skill that leads to a
paradigm shift
but it's also a skill that allows you to
regulate your nervous system very
quickly
and you know see problems from
multi-perspectival
perspectives that was not a true word i
think i just basically
i don't know perspective
uh you say in the book you say not going
big is bad for you
what do you mean by that all right uh
i'm gonna have to
there's a little bit of background we've
got to cover before i can explain this
so we talked earlier big performances
system getting your biology to work for
you rather than against you
so that biology while vast is limited
there's a set of motivational skills
there are a set of learning skills there
are creativity skills and there are flow
skills that's the sweet that's a
cognitive suite
to think about it easily just to frame
it for people motivation gets you into
the big performance game
learning allows you to continue to play
creativity is how we steer
flow is how we amplify the results right
that's that's the quick and dirty of the
formula
mode all these terms are catch-alls
right motivation is not
one thing it's compression you're
compressing yeah right
so motivation is actually extrinsic
motivation intrinsic motivation
goal setting and grit we're going to
focus to answer your question
predominantly on
intrinsic motivation what researchers
showed is there are five major intrinsic
motivators curiosity passion purpose
autonomy and mastery
and they are literally designed to come
online in an order
curiosity is designed to be cultivated
into passion which is designed to be
turned into purpose once you
know what your purpose is what do you
want freedom the autonomy to pursue your
purpose and once you have the freedom to
pursue your purpose what do you need
mastery the skills to pursue it well so
inside
of that
all of those uh autonomy curiosity
passion purpose autonomy and mastery
they
also do double duty as flow triggers
when we're curious about [ __ ] we pay
more attention to it our attention is
more focused on it we're more likely to
get into flow
et cetera et cetera so there are eight
major causes of depression right
but the point was we are designed to go
big we have a system it's designed to
help us achieve the impossible that much
is clear peak performance is
everybody's birthright and simply put
everybody can get into flow
flow is how we do peak performance it's
universal like
anybody anywhere can get into flow it's
task
unspecific it is race on specific sex
class
on and on and on it's ubiquitous in
human sexually ubiquitous in most
mammals
and definitely all social mammals
besides the point
um the point here is
we're designed to go big and not going
big is bad for us
why if you don't use any system the way
it's been designed to use
bad things happen so there are as i said
eight major causes of anxiety and
depression
these are the anxiety and depression by
the way are the largest epidemic in the
world
today right like and and we are losing
not only like one out of ten people in
the world is going to come down
with a clinical diagnosis of anxiety or
depression in the next year
and somebody kills themselves once every
12 seconds
so we're losing the fight and it's the
largest strain on public health coffers
in the world so big problem what are the
major causes of depression and anxiety
two of them are the ones that everybody
talks about and everybody thinks about
and they're actually kind of [ __ ] we
talk about
genetics and trauma i've got the wrong
genes i can't produce serotonin so i'm
depressed or i'm anxious
or this really bad thing happened i mean
i can't get over it right so i'm
depressed and i'm anxious
and it turns out we know really well
established science
depression and anxiety genetics is only
ever fifty percent of that equation
lifestyle history all that that's the
other half right
how we live how we have lived and how we
are going to live that's the other half
and trauma the fast fast vast vast
majority of the time
trauma leads to post-traumatic growth
this is how we like this is the world
breaks everyone and afterwards many are
stronger at the broken places to quote
hemingway
right we bad [ __ ] happens we
get through it and we're better for it
this is the vast majority of time
so what are the other six major causes
of depression if those two aren't all
that
real first most important one lack of
meaningful work
what does that actually mean what is it
technically under the hood
neurobiologically
it means work that i'm not curious about
that i'm not passionate about that is
not allowing my purpose or my strengths
that i can't
pursue in the way i would want to pursue
it so i have no freedom and it doesn't
offer me opportunities for mastery i'm
not getting better any skills that
really matter
to me right and taboo it doesn't produce
any flow
second one lack of meaningful values
well what does that mean that is
i don't have passion i don't have
purpose and i don't have flow and we can
literally go on and on and on to the
rest of them
we are designed to go big and we are
designed to rise to our full capability
and not trying to rise to our full
capability is bad for us
yes you talk in the book about uh
flow being also kind of governed by a
flywheel that
also is intrinsically limited by the
scarcity of resources that the resources
from physics and even just from common
sense are
fundamentally intrinsically limited and
i wonder you know
i i think about in the book uh when i
think about science
as an infinite game on one hand like you
can't win
science uh on the macro scale like you
never come to the end of science you
know science is john archibald wheeler
the teacher of richard feynman used to
say you know is a is a
battle to increase the island of
knowledge but the ocean of ignorance is
infinite so the coastline gets bigger
but the and the area of the island gets
bigger but you still have this infinite
infinite ocean out there uh so i want to
ask you you can't win
discover the schwartz child radius say
that one more time
didn't wheeler discover the schwartz
child radius he was
influential in many fields uh schwartz
child himself was that was a physicist
who discovered the solution the black
hole before einstein did
in uh in nineteen this but the
schwarzschild radius right
is the is the uh right at the point that
everything bends in and it didn't i
think wheeler created the equation that
governs it i think schwarzschild
wheeler coined the term black hole well
he's one of the
the the foremost exponents of that but
schwarzschild was almost 50 years
older than yeah uh we'll get to your
theories on
quantum electrodynamics in just a moment
stephen uh but i do want to ask you
um in science we have a series of finite
games
in that you know i want to win the nobel
prize i have only certain amount of
chances to get funding i got to get
tenure i got to support my graduate
students i have a payroll of a million
dollars a year literally
i make no profit i have only expenses i
have logistics i have concrete i got to
deliver to the south pole or the chile
i've got all these finite games and i
got competition i could get scooped i
could lose my nobel prizes
maybe i did the title of my book spoiler
alert but the point is steven
we have all these you know finite games
scarcity of research how do you get into
a flow state when you're when you're
battling
in an infinite game in a series of
finite games
it's very unlike a lot of uh of other
pursuits like art
you know no one's gonna paint the mona
lisa scoop me on the mona lisa
uh which is an infinite game too you
can't win art so how
what advice do you have maybe my that'll
be my last question before i get to one
final question
that i ask all my guests so how do you
survive the finite games
uh the the competition in the flow state
when when you have the scarcity of
resources in the finite games to win the
infinite game if you will of science
i want to start by saying i always tell
people
and mind you i work with some of the
best athletes
in the world i always say if you want to
see
what real competition looks like go to a
neuroscience conference
like i was like you you don't like
you've never like honest to god i've
said this professional football players
i'm like
no no you have no idea like
the worst most v besides a street gang
fight the most violent place i've ever
been to are
like you know the society for
neuroscience stephen there are more
people on the iss
right now floating around in space than
there are one nobel prizes in cosmos
so i i mean you're asking a question
about i mean you're asking a very very
difficult question but the short
answer is really about how do you stay
in the challenge skills sweet spot
how do you process anxiety right and
psychology has been really
like this is where really simply the
peak performance basics come into play
sciences said hey look if you want to
perform at your best
in any conditions especially competitive
ones where you there's gonna be extra
anxiety
right and you want to get into flow
anxiety will block flow because that
challenge skill sweet spot
is pretty thin too much anxiety will
kick you out
and then you can't get into flow so how
science is there's look there's three
things you can do
to fight anxiety you can have a daily
gratitude practice
a daily mindfulness practice or do
20 to 40 minutes of regular exercise and
if you're doing it for cognitive for
anxiety
you're basically looking for a nitric
oxide release but how what does that
feel like
when your lungs open up and your brain
gets quiet about 20 to 40 minutes into
exercise depending on
how in shape you are that there's been a
global release of nitric oxide in the
brain in the body it's pushed the stress
storms out of your system
you've reset the nervous system five
minutes of a gratitude practice will do
the same thing
and 11 minutes for stress reduction of a
meditative focus mindful respiration
practice will do the same thing
what we tell people to flow research
collective under normal conditions
do one a day if you're living in high
stress conditions
do two i would say if you're a scientist
you might want to think about three yes
right i really like
like i'm not joking and really like i
think it's one of the most competitive
difficult arenas to be in and
not for everyone um and you know it's
it it's it's no joke um you journalism
is another like it's saying that you can
get scooped it's the same like yeah
so it's this cauldron of like you've got
this artistic creative background
what we're all doing is innovative
creative
but and craft based in a sense and
what's built on top of it
is this incredibly cutthroat cruel
environment yeah i mean getting into the
major league is almost impossible right
and getting into triple a baseball also
as i understand it is almost as
almost as impossible but getting a
postdoc which is the the tier analogous
to getting into
aaa baseball is almost trivial i can do
it you know
but but the point being it's it's almost
a it's a total seller's market almost
anybody who wants a postdoc i have zero
unemployment for any of my students and
they're all great obviously but
but uh it's the point being is we set up
people in the academic ladder and these
are people who have a fight to get into
college
against the best and brightest in their
high school then college they had to get
into graduate school get graduate school
get a postdoc postdoc get a fellowship
fellowship get a scholarship
and keep going and at the apex it's just
like those you know
competing against these gladiators and
the best ones and then
there's no faculty job literally in my
field there hasn't been a faculty job in
experimental cosmic
studies where you build telescopes and
put them all around the world or in
space
in years steven and we set these people
up and it's
and it's cruel what we're doing to these
people is cruel and i feel terrible
and i've limited the number and it's
like you're turning away people that are
smarter than i am
and and it's and it's and it's and it's
there's something that i think is is
even cooler than in the uh academic
i'm sorry than the athletic realm that
you described i know your time is so
limited
uh i could talk to you for hours maybe
we'll do a part two stephen if you'll
indulge me
i do want to ask you at least one of my
thrilling three patented questions i
hope people will subscribe
uh and i hope that you will also uh tune
in to the episode i did with peter
diamandis steven's friend
we talked about you as well in that
episode i'll put a link to it here
uh in the in the youtube link and in the
show notes
i want to ask you um our sir arthur c
clarke i am the co-director of the rfc
clark center for human imagination
here at uc san diego we study creativity
imagination all the things you talk
about priming one
to get into that state in your wonderful
new book the art of the impossible
available now put links in the show
notes to buy it uh i want to ask you
arthur c clarke had many delicious
delightful laws
one of which is uh the any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic we
opened the show with his voice
from beyond the grave stephen to talk
about impossible i got that
that was an impossible get he reads that
says that wonderful statement
he says also for every expert stephen
there's an
equal and opposite expert so beware of
that but his third law will appeal to
you as it does to me
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
that's the origin of the name of this
podcast i want to ask you stephen
for advice to your former self what
mysterious
aspect of your life perplexed you as a
20 year old a 30 year old or maybe even
younger
but makes sense to you and what advice
would you give to your former self to
give you the courage to go into the
impossible as you have done
oh i don't know um i never think about
giving my former self advice because
honestly i
like i got exactly where i wanted to go
right so i don't want to mess with
anything
but if you know i like i it's that's an
interesting question
i um and somebody else asked me
something
the thing that would have been very
helpful because it's hard to know this
when you're younger
is that hard work works
or hard smart work works right and
i have spent i'll give you i've spent 20
years
asking most everybody i've met a simple
question which is tell me
things in your life that happened that
really mattered
where they shifted your life and it
massively impacted your performance on
the other end
you know what i've never heard oh there
was this time i got lucky and i found a
lottery ticket on the street like
it's i had to work three jobs with
myself through night school so i could
get into medical school so
like right those are the stories we tell
right and the truth about peak
performance is very
like there's a couple of difficulties
with peak performance one is that human
potential
is invisible the other is if you really
want to see what you're capable of it
works like compound interest
right it's a little bit today a little
bit tomorrow and when fought
two years three years four years that's
where it gets
starts to get really magnificent it's
exponential
um in its own way and like almost any
other exponentials
it's pretty invisible right we have a
linear bias built into the brain we
don't we're blind exponential as the
whole world discovered when covet
happened
and they were like how can it be
spreading so quickly well welcome to
exponentials
that's right this is this little thing
called math as you guys talk about in
your in your
ds and your 5ds which one of which is
diamandis but you should add a k in
there
stephen cutler thank you so much uh for
going into the impossible
and sharing the art of the uh of the
impossible you are impossibly delightful
to talk to
i hope you'll come back on the show we
could talk for hours as i said
uh we salute you and and uh really just
want to express our gratitude for all
you do for the world and the flow
collective
and we'll put links into all your
wonderful material much of which is free
and available on the internet
but i do hope people pick up this book
it's crucial for our times
uh that we're living in thank you steven
have a wonderful rest of your day thank
you brian that was really nice here
appreciate it
take care bye my friend any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this video i know you'll
love my video
with commander david marquet who wrote
the book turn the ship around
and leadership is language
and if you love books by stephen you'll
love his co-author's appearance on into
the impossible peter diamandis
click here for that and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]
you